Після багаторічних дискусій Верховна Рада таки скасувала депутатську недоторканність.
З січня наступного року народні обранці втратять імунітет.
За що їх зможуть притягнути до відповідальності
і як це працює на Заході?
Депутатську недоторканність українським обранцям гарантувала Конституція.
Там же було прописано і те, що депутатів не можна притягнути до кримінальної відповідальності,
затримати або заарештувати - без згоди  Верховної Ради.
В теорії це мало захищати обранців від можливого тиску
з боку виконавчої чи судової гілок влади.
Проте на практиці недоторканність українських депутатів
часто призводила до безкарності,
ба більше, ставала чи не головною причиною,
чому деякі одіозні кандидати взагалі прагнули здобути депутатський мандат.
Виключити ці положення з Основного закону ще кілька років тому
запропонував президент Петро Порошенко,
проте старій Раді цього так і не вдалося.
Скасування депутатської недоторканності, на думку критиків цієї ініціативи,
може бути потенційно небезпечним.
Мовляв, відсутність імунітету може використовуватися
для політичних переслідувань нардепів від опозиції.
З іншого боку, у депутатів залишається такий механізм захисту як індемнітет,
тобто їх неможливо притягнути до відповідальності за рішення
висловлювання у парламенті, окрім образ або наклепу.
А ось за кримінал - без проблем.
Західні політологи наголошують: депутатська недоторканність
добре працює в розвинутих демократіях, тоді як в Україні
цей інститут радше шкодить демократичним процесам.
Адже обранці часто використовували імунітет як особистий привілей,
щоб, приміром, уникнути покарання за махінації чи інші злочини.
Та чи інша форма депутатської недоторканності існує в абсолютній більшості країн.
Проте імунітет здебільшого діє лише у разі цивільних або адміністративних правопорушень
і не поширюється на кримінальні злочини.
Аби притягти до відповідальності або заарештувати, приміром, німецького депутата,
правоохоронці мають отримати згоду Бундестагу.
Проте якщо обранця затримали під час скоєння злочину
або на наступний день після цього,
згода парламенту на його арешт не потрібна.
Претензії до членів Бундестагу можуть бути різними:
від перевищення швидкості до причетності в корупції.
ле якщо порівнювати з українськими депутатами,
проступки їхніх німецьких колег - переважно дріб'язок.
Один з останніїх прикладів - скандал із членом фракції "зелених"
Фолькером Беком у 2016-му.
Його позбавили депутатського імунітету
через знайдені у нього пів грама метамфітаміну.
На Заході депутатський імунітет покликаний захищати обранців
насамперед від політичного тиску, а не призводити до безкарності.